they did not do well last night
they lost 24 to 10 and
as
coach matt nagy pointed out after the
game he was very distressed by the fact
that the defense for the bears scored
more points
than the offense
so
when you look at it was it the bear's
offense was just bad and continues to be
bad or is it that bear's offense ran up
against a pretty good defense and not
many teams were going to have a great
showing last night offensively against
l.a well it is a good defense there's no
doubt about that i don't think you know
again the rams have played solid
football pretty much on that side of the
ball all year long except you know last
week the 49ers showed a few cracks in
the seam right and then they had the
buffalo bills game right so there's a
lot of things to like they're very well
coached we know they got jalen ramsey
and leonard floyd and of course the best
defensive player in the game and aaron
donald but
more of the story than anything and as
much respect as i have for that rams
defense it is the bear's offense the
bear's offense is underwhelming i mean
it's it's it's
it's a it's a you know for lack of a
better phrase a lot of the times it's a
joke i don't know what other to say
there lacks creativity it lacks
toughness
the run game it's only one or two runs
the pass game
pre-snap movement motions things like
that that's few and far between so
there's nothing on the offensive side of
the ball in chicago to be real real
excited about their job is to
score a few points and not mess up the
game so the defense can win the game
and the defense gave them some
opportunities to at least hang in there
you know it wasn't their best night
either but you can't throw you know
interceptions in the red zone and you
can't you know not not get any points
when you're inside the 10-yard line and
you're going forward down there in the
end and all of that you know that that
just was is part of the the bigger
problem in chicago they got offensive
issues there's no doubt they have to
always play through their defense to win
a football game
yeah and i tell you they did have
opportunities last night and there was a
drive in the third quarter where
they had to stop and go
and receiver was gone
and nick foles when when you watched it
live it looked like foals just missed
the game sure
but but kudos to espn for pulling up the
replay that showed how
the bear's offensive line
overreacted to the presence
of aaron donald on the left side of the
rams defensive line making the bears
vulnerable on the left side of their
offensive line guys crashed through nick
foles had to get rid of the football
before he really wanted to he actually
threw the ball
as the receiver was executing the stop
yeah before the go and
jaylen ramsey would have been wearing
the goat horns today in our draft coming
up in the final hour of the program
goats in a bad way for week seven
because he got flat out roasted on that
one chris
but they they just didn't connect
because nick foles had to get rid of the
ball early and and that's one of the
things that matt nagy pointed out he
said that's not a criticism to any
player
but the reality is the offense failed to
get it done and he's got concerns about
the running game which isn't there of
course
the offensive line what do you do and
that's what he said last night after the
game do you take this guy out do you
take that guy out what do you do you
just hope the guys find a way to get
better and that's the challenge you know
teams do get better throughout the
course of the season but it's not the
easiest thing in the world to do because
it's not like you can just press a
button and get a better player sometimes
you get guys back from injury sometimes
you get lucky and a guy like quentin
spain becomes available there's a report
that he's likely to sign with the
bengals i mean there are guys that pop
up yeah but for the most part it's on
the coaching staff to come up with
better ways
to play to the strengths
and disguise and cover and minimize the
weaknesses of the players that they have
yeah well that's right and they you know
they don't they don't do that that well
either now listen the point you bring up
about their offense line it is very real
it is an average average offensive line
there's not one area you look at you can
go oh well they pass protect well or oh
they pull guards well or they zone block
well none of that no so that is where
matt nagy is certainly you know stuck a
little bit because they had never had
that opportunity to kind of impose their
will on a football game let alone when
there is somewhere to run or do
something they don't have a running back
that can take advantage of it so that's
the other thing that hurts them too so
now the o-line who's been dominated you
know four run plays in a row that fifth
play whoa we opened up a gap here's 20
yards
they you know david montgomery he's more
of a short yardage back he can make you
miss but as you could see speed is not
his forte and he's just not going to rip
off any plays that way either so my the
big thing with the the chicago and this
is something i've been talking about
like what what are they trying to do
what is the
what is the identity of their defense
it's this offense excuse me it's the
second year in a row we're having this
conversation and you know i don't care
but just what you know it's it's shotgun
spread and then it's under the center
and then the next play oh we decide to
motion and do like a cool kansas city
speed sweep fake or whatever and then we
don't see that again for 10 plays and
then all sudden it's back it comes back
again so that would be my big thing to
them is like you're saying mike find
that thing even though it might not be
that great just find the thing that you
go all right we're pretty good at this
and we can build on it and let's go from
there and i don't know what that is
short passing game screens whatever it
is they got to figure it out
how about this tweet from nfl research
the bears had 49 yards rushing last
night against the rams
that was the bear's fourth consecutive
game with fewer than 65 rushing yards
the only time they have had four
straight such games in the super bowl
era that's like impossible this day and
age
to have 65 or fewer for four straight
games yes it's almost impossible with
all the creative ways to run the
football the speed sweeps the reverses
we see every week mike i mean usually
your quarterback can scramble and get
almost 65 yards a game doing that stuff
in this day and age in the nfl so that's
that speaks to it like it just shows you
what are the what pressure are they
putting on the defense right oh it's
falls in the shotgun oh okay he's gonna
throw it five yards or he's gonna sit in
the pocket and wait for somebody he's
gonna throw into a crowd of four people
down the field i mean that's really what
their offense looks like at times sorry
i didn't mean to cut you off man sorry
no you're fine no but but you know when
you can't run the ball how in the world
do you throw the ball your play action
game is meaningless you become one
dimensional that's right another point
that nagi made last sure you can't be
one dimensional unless you have
a high-powered passing attack which they
don't they need to have the defense
creeping up to stop the run in order to
get the most out of the passing game
yeah and look i don't know if they made
a play for le'veon bell
i don't know that bell would have even
been interested in the chicago bears but
as the trade deadline approaches if this
team wants to continue
to somehow
win five out of seven games and somehow
is even more appropriate for the bears
than it is for the browns frankly
but if the bears want to continue this
they need to be thinking about who's out
there what's out there what they can do
to make it better lesean mccoy fallen
out of favor in tampa bay leonard
fournette's the new third down back
mccoy had zero touches he didn't even
enter the game he was the only running
back who was in uniform in week
seven who did not play for his team why
not give the bucks a call and throw him
a late round pick and get lesean mccoy
he's been in that offense he was last
year in kansas city he can't be any
worse than the guys they have you just
got to be creative you got to think
about what's out there and try to make
your team better on the fly right or or
uh forget about five and two five and
two is gonna be five and four very
quickly for the bears because they got
the saints and the titans up next yeah
unless they find some answers and then
and then it's just gonna it's gonna it's
gonna cascade downhill for the bears and
they're going to be one of those teams
and we see him every year take the bingo
off the screen we see him every year
where there's a team that starts strong
and then at the end of the day they
don't make it to the playoffs yeah
they're left wondering what the hell
happened no you're right well i think
you know they schedule fell you know
nice for them here to start the year
some very comfortable opponents
certainly got the kind of the unexpected
win against the buccaneers who kind of
let one slip away where they kind of
controlled the game and messed up the
end of the first half and all that hey
i'm not like
giving up on them totally but i hear
what you're saying yeah i mean right now
you sit here and i go yeah they're going
to lose the saints and they're going to
lose the titans of course they are i
mean any team that has some sort of
offense and defensive balance it's going
to be strugglesville for the chicago
bears and what they do and i don't know
mike yeah i don't know if you go to the
trade deadline and do you just go you
know what the offense is a lost cause
the hell with it i don't care we there's
nobody out there that's going to help us
you know maybe they do that and then
they just go let's just make the defense
better maybe let's get another shutdown
corner maybe another pass rusher you
know maybe they do something like that
and they just go all in on that side of
the ball but they got to figure
something out to help the defense out
the defense is a borderline super bowl
caliber defense i mean every week they
cause turnovers they almost score
touchdowns i mean last week they had
against carolina i believe they had
one touchdown called back and of course
they set up the bears to score an easy
five-yard touchdown because they
intercepted the ball early in the game
and teddy bridgewater they can almost
win games by themselves if the offense
could just help them a little bit and
stay on the field and do that and mike
you know you brought up like what do you
do when you can't run the ball right the
team that you live not far from
they are doing it a little bit the
pittsburgh steelers now the running game
has come
but they do the de facto run game
through the short passing game too and
just i'm just throwing out an example of
it can be done where you just hey screen
this way screen this way tight end
screen running back screen and you use
that as the run game as the run game is
a work in progress and then people start
to worry about that and then your run
game all of a sudden has a little
success and maybe that's the way they go
because they certainly just can't line
up and run after people or run at people
easier easier to do though when you can
send multiple great receivers down
which the bears don't have the bears
don't have to open everything up
underneath they just don't have that i
mean they don't have the personnel the
worst thing they could have done was
stack up those wins early because now
they're gonna have this sense of
foreboding and i think folks in chicago
have had it all year long even at five
and one yeah they have that the bottom's
gonna fall out of this thing because all
they have to do is watch the games and
they wonder what the hell is going on
and to nick full's point from last week
winning ugly is better than losing
pretty
but both are way better
than losing ugly and that's what we saw
last night all right there was an issue
that came up
during garbage time last night when
the guys in the booth have to fill right
the game's not very good brian griese
told a story about talking to nick foles
the day before the game about issues
with communication and whether the plays
are
coming in quickly enough and whether or
not he can get them called on time
greasy shared that
after the game both nick foles and matt
maggie reacted to what griezy had to say
here they are
uh this is what he said nick relayed to
him sometimes play calls come in
and i don't know that i have the time to
execute that play call and i'm the one
out here getting hit sometimes the guy
calling the plays matt nagy he doesn't
know how much time there is back there
and so that's something they have to
work out that's just what was said on
the broadcast yeah i i don't i don't
know we you'll have to whenever you talk
to nick just kind of see where he's at
with that i i
that's not
nick and i have a pretty good
relationship and he hasn't said i mean
he'll probably explain what he meant by
that so when coach niagi and i talk on
the sidelines we'll go through plays in
different situations and go through a
defense and i'll be honest like hey you
know right now maybe get the ball
quicker um they're bringing some
pressures what not so
uh we were talking about game situations
and game you know
different you know coach naggy and i's
conversations in our relationship so
um part of that was you know the detail
hey maybe we don't have the time right
now for this type of drop
because of what they're bringing and the
pressures are bringing it's easier with
that hey one two three ball out so
that's where the miscommunication lies
is those are actually conversations
coach maggie and i have on the sidelines
um so that when we go to the field we're
ready to roll
so look who knows without having a
recording of the conversation between
foals and greasy from the day before the
game
it's unclear whether it was falls
venting a little bit maybe thinking it
wasn't going to be used that's where i
always go with something like that yeah
greasy cut falls in a candid moment
greasy shared it when he shouldn't have
and now you got guys who have to scrape
toothpaste off the floor and put it back
in the tube and it's going to be a
little awkward in three weeks when the
bears are on monday night football again
and greasy is talking to foals and naggy
it'd be interesting to see whether or
not they want to talk to him yeah but
you know it's it's a real point
are you calling plays that give your
quarterback enough time to get rid of
the ball when your offensive line sucks
all due respect too late for that but
when you have this double move that
you've been waiting to unleash and it
pops and your quarterback doesn't have
time to get rid of the ball because the
offensive line can't keep the defensive
line away from him for three seconds
what what can you do yeah and so and but
here's the thing how many plays do you
have in your playbook where the
quarterback actually throws the football
fast enough
to compensate for a bad offensive line
no well and you know mike even on that
play itself and you know i need to go
back and watch it one more time but you
know you got five offensive linemen
you know there's there's there's there
was five rushers there right that was
there was four four down linemen and
only one guy off the edge so first off
like is that your plan as an offense i
mean this just speaks to the bigger
problem you know one the really good
offenses in that situation still would
go
okay wait wait they're gonna bring the
blitz over here let's figure out we can
go five on five yeah we got a trouble
with aaron donald now he'll be one on
one but you have to be aware and just
get the ball out of your hand and
hopefully that double move we're talking
about right now that'll buy you just
enough time to maybe see him come out of
that break to where you can throw the
appropriate ball or there has to be a
better plan to just throw the ball
quickly in that situation because it's
not realistic to think that you're going
to get that type of route off versus a
free blitzer running off the edge that
way so that would be the first thing i
would talk about but yeah i want to
throw the challenge flag on just about
everything there that was said in that
you know first off it looked like nick
foles dodged the converse the
conversation the question to me greasy
and i heard him say it last night too
live and i kind of popped up a little
bit
like
i thought he was more referring to at
times they make play calls in the huddle
too
and you know it might be two play calls
right like hey we got this pass play in
this pass play for the two defenses i
expect here and he's breaking the huddle
or he's in the huddle and he's going
wait there's 15 seconds left i can't get
to the line of scrimmage and execute all
those type of things that you're asking
me to do so now i'm going to be stuck
just running one of them and we're in
trouble and i thought that's more of
what he was speaking to rather than the
drop thing maybe i'm wrong maybe i need
to re-hear the quote one more time do we
do we have the quote in writing anywhere
or anything
it is confusing because i think greasy
created the perception it was about
getting the plays yes actually called
shooting the play right and then but
then when he says that foles is the one
who's getting hit that's when it opens
the door to this idea that it's about
the duration of the play before you get
rid of the football so it is confusing
it is confusing and and and look that's
hey that's part of the challenge if
you're going to be talking to these guys
and if you i i do it every week man you
got to make sure you you get what these
guys said and you understand what they
said if you're going to relay these
conversations you got to get it right
and uh you know it's it sounds like
there's an issue there
and uh but but regardless we don't need
nick foles to vent
or not
with brian griese to understand there's
an issue of course there's an issue
every time he throws the ball he's got
guys hanging all over him you know and
he's standing in the pocket and he's and
he's taking a big hit and eventually
he's going to get injured i mean you you
can't get ragdoll around like that when
you're built the way he is and not
eventually get injured chris all right
how about some praise for the los
angeles rams
five and two they have now expanded
their ability to win football games
beyond the nfc east congratulations for
that way to go around for the rams you
beat a team outside of the nfc east well
done you still have six games to play
against teams well you know five because
you lost to the 49ers you still got to
win one in your division we'll see if
they can do that coming up but at least
for now they got to five and two here is
sean mcvay coach of the rams on his team
performing better this week in prime
time than they did last week in prime
time against san francisco
i thought we did a good job you know the
red zone score that gerald everett had
thought was big you know being able to
hit josh reynolds earlier in the game
was a big deal so overall was pleased
with that you know this is a great
defense wanted to try to minimize some
of the opportunities for their elite
guys to be able to rush and get home and
you know they even found a way to still
score defensively but but we knew what a
great outfit they were we knew how
responsible they were for a lot of their
wins that they had and the way that they
got it done wanted to minimize those
chances and i thought those guys did a
really good job executing the plan
let me just let me just vent about
something real quickly because this is
about praising the rams and sean mcvay
is a great coach in the nfl but one of
the nfl's twitter accounts last night
put up the video of him two years ago
when they were getting ready to play the
bears and he rattled off the names of
all the stars come on folks if you're an
offensive head coach and you don't know
the names of all the starters on the
opposing defense the week you're getting
ready to play them what the hell are you
what are you doing coaching football
anywhere right yes i know am i right no
you you're right i mean i feel like you
and me can sit there and rattle off
starters of the teams as you know easily
i mean my god if it's if that's the next
team we're playing and we're studying
their film and we're trying to figure
out how we're going to stop these guys
you better damn know their names if you
don't what are you doing in this
industry so anyway well he's kid genius
and he's made a name for himself with
his ability to recall plays and all that
so people just love it now that he's
that way
but but i remember last year when it
happened it wasn't fashionable to point
out that he was anything other than a
genius so i bit my tongue two years ago
when the rams were on that track and
they were the
the the flavor of the month and all that
but but i saw that again last night it's
like aren't we past that don't we
understand that any head coach knows
and if and if he doesn't he shouldn't be
a head coach you shouldn't be a head
coach all right but but the rams
are doing well their offense did enough
yeah their defense did more than enough
i don't know how that offense is going
to hold up you know when you're going
against a team with a great offense it's
one thing to say okay we can score
enough points against a pretty good
defense because we know our defense is
good enough to make a bad offense do
nothing but that's my concern about the
rams going forward they can do a game
with a team like the seahawks can their
defense slow them down enough to let the
rams offense outscore seattle or arizona
for that matter yeah yeah i think so i
mean you know seattle's defense is so
bad i think so but mike i think your
question is real i think that's probably
my biggest question about them as a
football team really it is that yeah
okay they're playing a team similar to
them right you know and okay it's a team
that yeah they can score some points and
got pretty good balance but they got a
good enough defense to take away some of
the mcveigh tricks right where we saw
last night like some of them were
working and at times they hit a little
stall a stale point you know and and i
think what you're saying is the same
thing i'm saying which is for two weeks
in a row you see when the mcveigh tricks
and the bootlegs and the run game isn't
just absolutely dominating can the drop
back pass game of the rams actually win
you a football game and i think that's
still a very big question about them you
know if the speed sweeps the inside zone
and all those things that mcveigh does
off that and the pace and the tempo and
all that that doesn't create an
advantage can
can jared goff drop back and just tear
you apart i don't know i still think
that's very up in the air he has moments
where i say yes and then he has moments
where i say no either way though
the one thing that i think we really got
to give credit for sean mcvay he's very
special this way the way he manages the
football game what he said right there
he realized their offense can't beat us
it's their defense that i'm more worried
about beating us causing turnovers
giving the short field causing a
turnover and just scoring a touchdown in
general i mean the bears were this close
to really doing that but mcveigh
the way he calls the game he's very
patient he understands the big picture
of the game he played field position
last night he just wore them down with
field position and used the third phase
of football that we never talk about and
slowly just beat the bears into the
ground with that and that's where i got
to give him a lot of credit to his
ability to see the big picture of the
football game
and in that third phase it was johnny
hecker with some great hands five inside
the 20 i believe a 63 yarder at a time
when
it felt like there was an opening for
the bears you know it was 24 to 3. turn
out the lights the party's over and then
lightning strike fumble
scoop score for the bears it's 24-10
then a three and out it's like okay this
is getting interesting and then johnny
hecker kicks the ball 63 yards
completely flips the field and and
that's amazing that's that's right
especially because on that next drive
right but well it was one of the drives
near the end of the game i think it was
that drive that resulted in the jaylen
ramsey interception right it felt like
the bears thought it was the third
quarter not the fourth quarter like we
need some urgency here he's down 14.
somebody yell can somebody do something
get going like show emotion yes i'm with
you i mean a geez i mean
i know it's cool to be calm and relaxed
but
i'm with you there's just no urges
there's no leadership who's the guy on
the offense that's that guy i thought
you know nick foles is cool calmness but
there's no fire on that side of the ball
for the bears
but that's the demeanor of a team that
knows it doesn't matter i think that's
what it comes down to that no matter
what they do
in that spot with five minutes left
there's no way in hell an offense that
has mustered three points the entire
game against the rams is going to score
two touchdowns and i think that's what
creeps in and somebody needs to step up
in that moment and grab some guys by the
shirt caller and say we let's go and
show some urgency nick foles wasn't
doing that now you know and this gets
back to the old thing of how well a guy
plays when things are going well how
well a guy plays when things aren't
going well but we've seen foals lead
this team from behind i just think that
everyone knew
at that point
that offense just isn't built at this
point to score the points necessary
against the rams late they knew they've
been out there getting humbled by that
defense all night there's a point where
the human being takes over it's that i
just want to go home and go to bed vibe
that we get from time to time from a
team and we got that i'm glad you picked
up on it too yeah
they they just had the look and the feel
and this is what you know sometimes the
broadcasters don't want to criticize but
you got to say what it is you got to
enhance the viewing experience you got
to let the average person know what the
hell guys the clock's ticking let's go
you know let's let's move the ball here
and and create the impression and and
really draw the the thread that that
would suggest that there was just a lack
of basical quality yes to the bears
offense late in the game because i think
they knew we all knew well and it must
have you know and that's where i go back
to like the greasy quote and all that
about not getting the you know maybe
plays in quickly enough and just there's
not enough of a urgency that way i don't
know either way there's major issues on
that offense i hope chicago the city can
take notice and go oh wait maybe it
wasn't all mitchell trubisky's fault
okay i think people are going to start
to realize that because we're here and
now that's four games in a row and it
ain't been anything special from nick
foles everybody chicago fans it's
nothing special i mean he he did a lot
of dumb crap last week in the carolina
win he did dumb crap last night i
thought he was supposed to be the one
that managed the game and do that stuff
the colts game wasn't good you know he
got that bucks game which was still just
middle of the road playing but you know
nonetheless it hasn't been as good as i
would have expected
but i don't know why i expected so much
anyways i knew the offense stunk
schematically players on the field all
of those issues i just hope people maybe
get off mitch dubris
look at the numbers look at the numbers
three touchdowns five picks eight sacks
averaging 237.8 yards per game and
here's the thing mds pointed this out on
twitter earlier uh in the hour in the
three games that mitchell trubisky
started the bears had 300 or more yards
of offense in the four games
that foles has started under 300 yards
of total offense so
look what
whatever it was that caused matt nagy to
go with foals over trubisky
he had a gut feeling at some point that
he needed to do it and you just wonder
whether or not what's gone on in recent
weeks what went on last night and this
whatever it was that he said to brian
greasy starts to plant the seeds for a
gut feeling to flip it back to mitchell
trubisky
and and you've got some tests coming up
saints
yeah titans right the next two weeks for
the chicago bears and then they have a
monday night game against the vikings
and then it's a bye week and then they
get their introduction to the green bay
packers whom they have not yet it was in
2012 it was 17-3 and they were inside
what the 15-yard line i mean the game's
gonna be different if they just even
kick a field goal it's gonna be a
different game that was that you can't
make that interception you can't make
that throw in the back left in the end
zone that gets tipped up in the air that
was that was the end of the game right
there they drove down scored the game
bye-bye
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports